Matt is on Twitter Dave did you ever use
your emergency fund that you had when
you were in baby step one well Matt full
disclosure are the baby steps I invented
or not invented when I was there
actually we started Financial Peace
University the baby steps weren't there
I was teaching the class Financial Peace
University and we started working out
and realizing that people didn't know
what to do first and what the new second
and what to do third and we started
coming up with that and when we first
start teaching the class with an
overhead projector in a bad suit in a
hotel ballroom and you know we have
hundreds of people in there we break up
into these small groups and I'm sitting
there every night for years talking to
people and I started realizing that
people needed this they needed to know
what to do next because half the
questions about this once you get
started here what to do next what to do
next what to do next what to do next
what does the where's the debt snowball
come in you know was the what do we what
about the emergency fund and why I don't
want to stop my retirement and well you
need to because you're going to get out
of debt well why well how am I know when
to do that and so we had to lay all of
that out and truthfully the first many
hundreds if not thousands of families
that came through Financial Peace
University didn't even have the baby
steps there so now I will tell you this
having gone through going broke going
bankrupt losing everything we owned we
were twenty eight years old we had a
brand-new baby and a toddler our
marriage is hanging on by a thread I
felt like an idiot because I was an
idiot Sharon was terrified our marriage
we really kill each other so you need to
understand what those scars and how our
relationship with those scars in our
history we don't just have an emergency
fund now we have an emergency fund for
the emergency fund I mean she doesn't
want to if we even got near that
emergency fund for anything even for an
illegitimate emergency she would have
had what we in Tennessee call it duct
fit I'm not sure exactly what a duct fit
is but apparently when a duct gets in a
fit it's not a good thing because my
wife has a duct fitting a good thing you
know
I'm saying so that's the deal you know
and I'm joking around here but not much
that's really the truth and so that you
know we just don't touch the emergency
fund because that opens up those wounds
it opens up those scars of her feeling
terrified or insecure are those kinds of
things so even when we had an emergency
we would just stop doing something else
like if the heating and air went out you
know that's a legitimate thing put heat
in their unit on there but nuke we
stopped doing something else and you
know maybe sell something maybe have a
garage sell that weekend I don't know we
scrape up the money we didn't even use
the emergency fund for emergencies but
that's got to do with the scars in the
background just to be full disclosure
but no there was not a baby step one
when I was there because there was no
baby steps when I was there I was still
you know trying to figure this crap out
just to feed my kids and figure out what
to do next after losing everything from
being an idiot so if you've ever been
stupid I mean you know what I'm talking
about I got a PhD in D um B y'all hey
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh